in the books Harry is described as
having a thin face knobbly knees black
hair and bright green eyes in the movies
Daniel Radcliffe plays Harry however
there are some noticeable differences
between his appearance and the book
description for one thing Daniel has
blue eyes not green because he was
allergic to the contact lenses that
would have changed his eye color also
some fans have said Harry scar should
look like more realistic lightning like
this rather than the cartoonish one we
got in the films next we have Harry's
best friend and the brightest Witch of
her age Hermione Granger in the books
Hermione is described as having bushy
brown hair large front teeth and brown
eyes in the movies Emma Watson plays
Hermione however her appearance is also
different from the book description Emma
has Sleek wavy hair not bushy and her
teeth are normal size not larger than
average moving on we have Harry's other
best friend and the youngest son of the
Weasley family Ron Weasley in the books
Ron is described as having a long nose
freckles and bright red hair in the
movies Rupert grin plays Ron and he's
very similar to the book description the
only difference is that rert is not as
tall and skinny as Ron is supposed to be